It's Pevan and Sarah.
The sun is shining and it's a beautiful day.
I think it's time to play outside.
Would you like to play catch, Sarah?
OK, get ready to catch.
Sarah, are you hurt?
Did the world explode?
Is this the worst thing that could ever happen to you?
You only dropped a ball.
Making mistakes is an important part of learning.
You need to just focus on catching the ball...
...and don't take your eyes off it.
Do you think you've learned something now?
Let's try again.
All right?
Focus and eyes on the ball.
Ready to catch.
See?
You did learn something.
You learned from your mistakes.
Well done, Sarah.
And remember, Cubs, it's okay to make mistakes.